il robot ci ruberanno il lavoro
questo è quello che leggete su tutti i
giornali
ma perché ci preoccupiamo perché il
lavoro nobilita beh io credo che questa
sia una narrazione che ci hanno messo in
testa ma che dobbiamo cercare di
ripensare il nuovo e critico il lavora
un mezzo non è un film
in questo lavoro questo è il lavoro
inventato dalla rivoluzione industriale
seconda metà del settecento prima metà
dell'ottocento la prima rivoluzione
industriale
cos'ha fatto ha creato la fabbrica
creato il lavoro nella fabbrica ha
creato questo mito del lavoro prima non
c'era questo mito del lavoro
dell'operare c'era l'artigiano che era
anche artista pensate all'artigiano del
rinascimento oppure c'era il contadino
c'era la terra c'era un rapporto più
diretto con ciò che si faceva ciò che
era la propria aspirazione ciò che si
sapeva fare ciò che si desidera da fare
e non sto parlando chiaramente degli
schiavi sto parlando di un lavoro che
possa avere un senso per chi lo fa con
la rivoluzione dustriale s'è creato un
schema diverso un lavoro schiavo perché
questo sono di fatto gli operai in una
catena di montaggio potrei parlare ore
di questo problema evidentemente
ricordate qualcuno si ricorderà chaplin
le famose nei tempi moderni dell'uomo
dell'omino nell'ingranaggio questo è il
lavoro questa è un'abilità questa è una
schiavitù il lavoro nella miniera il
lavoro faticoso pericoloso e questo
invece nello scenario moderno alla
robotica ha reso possibile liberare
l'uomo dalla schiavitù del lavoro oggi
nella fabbrica questo genere di lavori
vengono svolti da macchina robot è
l'uomo è quello che inventa che crea che
decide ma non rischia la propria salute
facendo un certo tipo di lavori e allora
vedete che il bene è insito nella
ricerca scientifica perché il nostro
lo scopo del nostro lavoro dovrebbe
essere fare qualcosa di utile assicurare
il progresso anche se come vedremo il
cammino del progresso è tutt'altro che
limpido e lineare automatico e quindi
qualche esempio per esempio la robotica
medica potrei fare un infinità di esempi
perché di fatto
cos'è la roma dove robot è una macchina
con dentro computer con dentro del
software con dentro e dell'intelligenza
artificiale quindi tutto sta diventando
un robot perché ormai sapete che
qualunque elettrodomestico qualunque
macchina ormai ave dotata di calcolatori
collegate in rete nella medicina per
esempio sta sviluppando cose
straordinarie questo che vedete è il
famosissimo roba da vinci che permette
di fare interventi chirurgici
minimamente invasivi con elevatissime
proprietari successo e ridottissimi
effetti collaterali ma è solo l'inizio
di quello che potrà fare la robotica
chirurgica mini microinvasiva oppure
come in questo caso c'è tutto il settore
della bionica potrà sviluppare protesi a
organi arti artificiali per sostituire
elementi danneggiati e quindi restituire
agli esseri umani la piena funzionalità
qui vedete
uno dei più avanzati prototipi di amy
che ricevi comandi tramite dei sensori
sulla parte residua del braccio quindi
pensa ad un certo addestramento ma
pensando uno stimolo si riesce ad
estrarre la mente e l'intelligenza
artificiale di questo abbraccio a
muoversi solo col pensiero come facciamo
con un braccio naturale
sono due i mille esempi di come
chiaramente la robotica è in grado di
migliorare il nostro futuro e rendersi
utile però come dicevo ogni macchina
diventa un robot e ogni macchina è
collegata in rete oggi sapete che la
rete dappertutto l'avete in tasca
qualunque smartphone ormai tramite il 4g
tra l'altro milano adesso sta per
sperimentare il 5 g
la rete dappertutto tutto è collegato
alla rete i robot non faranno
assolutamente eccezione saranno
collegati alla rete sia per funzioni
banali tipo scaricare le nuove release
del software che ormai fate
quotidianamente sui morti su marco ma
potranno fare di più nel senso che
esattamente come uno smartphone voi
potrete comprare qualunque tipo di robot
abbastanza nudo con una dotazione di
software abbastanza basica e poi
scaricare le app quindi lo stesso robot
voi potrete comprarle fargli fare il
cuoco un altro potrà comprarlo fargli
fare il cronista e un altro potrà fargli
fare il maggiordomo quindi avremo queste
macchine capaci di interagire con
l'ambiente con gli esseri umani piene di
alpe piene di software e per di più
dotate di intelligenza ufficiale quindi
di capacità di apprendere e di prendere
decisioni in modo autonomo e di evolvere
quindi perché l'apprendimento robotico
implica la capacità di sviluppare
comportamenti non programmati
all'origine dal costruttore e quindi in
questo scenario vedete come vi sia un
nuovo ecosistema che sta nascendo in cui
c'è la rete il cloud questo mostro che
ci governa
dentro cui ci stanno tutti i nostri dati
avete letto negli ultimi giorni lo
scandalo di facebook con cambridge
analitica e diciamo il grande pubblico
comincia a rendersi conto del fatto che
la privacy non esiste più
sostanzialmente non esiste perché tutto
quello che facciamo in qualunque modo
viene tracciato liste mai chiesti come
fa google maps
se lo usate in tempo reale come
navigatore a dirvi che fra trecento
metri c'è la coda perché lui riceve la
posizione da tutte le persone che in
quel momento hanno il telefonino hanno
una login un account su gmail su google
e quindi in realtà lui sa esattamente
dove ciascuno di noi
e così può con l'algoritmo
all'intelligence ufficiale calcolare il
percorso tenendo conto del traffico ma
questo significa che qualcuno sa dove
siete
e ne tiene traccia ma sa anche cosa fate
cosa non fate cosa comprate cosa
guardate con chi chattate con che
parlate
tutti questi dati sono i famosissimi big
data che elaborati dell'intelligenza
artificiale possono produrre risultati
utili per esempio qui vedete un caso
questa è la famosa guida autonoma della
tesla
la gente pensa che l'autovettura guida
autonoma sia una macchina con dentro un
robot che la guida con un cervello non è
esattamente così
nel senso che le macchine noi
classifichiamo l'autonomia della
macchina in cinque livelli no 5 e la
macchina completamente autonoma in grado
di guidare da sola in qualunque
condizione senza nessun tipo di
intervento umano
ebbene noi adesso saremo su un grado 3 4
più o meno nel senso che riesce a fare
certe cose ma non tutte e solo in certe
condizioni per raggiungere il livello 5
in realtà sarà necessario che queste
macchine sempre collegati in rete non
usino la loro intelligenza locale che
sarà un intelligenza estremamente
limitata ma usino l'intelligenza in rete
l'intelligenza collettiva
e i dati in rete occorreva che tutte le
macchie che a priori chiaramente ci sarà
una fase di messa a punto del sistema
poi qualunque macchina allo stesso modo
in cui ho detto che google conosce la
vostra posizione quindi può calcolare il
traffico verrà memorizzato ogni metro di
strada continuamente in tutte le
condizioni di giorno di notte con la
pioggia con la nebbia col vento con la
neve per cui quando questa macchina farà
un certo percorso in tempo reale
riceverà dalla rete istruzioni su cosa
aspettarsi in quel metro
quest'informazione non potrà essere
presente a priori nella macchina che
comperate sarà elaborata in tempo reale
mentre alla macchina guida e quindi
l'intelligenza nostra dentro la macchina
starà in flauto da qualche parte e
questo sarà per qualunque tipo di robot
non non dovete immaginare appunto come
infine fantascienza l'umanoide io non ho
messo filmato il meno di apposta classic
umanoide col cervello posytron ico come
quelli di asimo avremo robot di tutte le
forme di tutte le specie di tutte le
caratteristiche tutti collegati in rete
tutti che faranno riferimento a questa
intelligenza collettiva che potrà
diventare anche con connettiva nel senso
che ogni robot dirà in continuazione
cosa sta facendo e come sta funzionando
quindi l'esperienza di ci sarà questa
diciamo superintelligenza robotica
questa super intelligenza artificiale e
potrebbe essere che i robot che avete
davanti
non è altro che un terminale come può
essere il vostro smartphone
quando fate girare un app che localmente
gira solo l'interfaccia e poi il
programma realtà viene svolto da qualche
altra parte
quindi vi rendete conto della
complessità del quadro noi vivremo
immersi in questo nuovo ecosistema che è
completamente nuovo perché non avremo la
nostra stessa libertà di comprendere la
realtà di prendere decisioni sarà
condizionata dal dall'input di tutta
questa tecnologia in cui saremo immersi
e ed ecco il problema il problema è il
vecchissimo classico problema del dual
use of technology doppio uso della
tecnologia c'è un coltello
utilissimo taglia il pane qualunque il
formaggio però perché tagliare la gola
ma chi è che decide e chi impugna il
coltello in questo caso vedete fermi
sviluppato la conoscenza dell'energia
nucleare per motivi scientifici per
motivi di ricerca di curiosità e
sappiamo che l'energia nucleare può
essere utile a dare energia alimentare
un'intera città così come a renderla
completamente al suolo in pochi secondi
ma come facciamo a decidere diventa una
questione sostanzialmente umana siamo
noi che abbiamo in pugno il manico del
coltello oppure gestiamo l'uso
dell'energia nucleare oppure cerchiamo
di gestire lo sviluppo l'impiego della
robotica e allora ecco perché è
importante la roboetica la robotica è
nuovo voi conoscete di più la bioetica
perché è nata una trentina d'anni prima
la roboetica è nata più o meno
quindicina d'anni fa per affrontare un
etica applicata cioè l'etica è il
tentativo di sviluppare un codice umano
pratico che implementi la morale ciò che
noi sentiamo dentro ma si deve adattare
cioè chiaramente l'etica di quando
facevamo i pastori è differente dall
etica che dobbiamo sviluppare per
gestire che sono appunto le
biotecnologie nel caso della bioetica o
le nuove tecnologie robotiche quindi
questo sforzo che stiamo facendo molti
di noi robotici per coinvolgere la
società nel suo complesso quindi esperti
di di giurisprudenza di medicina di
psicologia di filosofia per affrontare
queste problematiche che si chiamano els
e cioè ethical legal social aspects cioè
aspetti etici legali e sociali perché
quello che leggete se un robot fa un
danno di chi ha la responsabilità per
esempio quelle come facciamo a garantire
che un robot non faccio un danno oppure
che tipo di robot dobbiamo sviluppare
che etico sviluppare un robot per
esempio baby sitter cioè fa bene al
bambino essere accudito da una macchina
oppure è etico sviluppare robot per
prestazioni sessuali oppure etico
sviluppare robot che uccidono in guerra
io penso di no evidentemente soprattutto
nell'ultimo caso nel senso che abbiamo
enormi problemi con la robotica militare
non è l'argomento della giornata per
ogni bene ha sempre questo rovescio
della medaglia fare il bene
richiede si fare il bene ma anche
lavorare per impedire il male e allora
eccoci che ci troviamo come società ad
affrontare problemi di estrema
complessità che richiederanno molto
impegno cioè se noi saremo passivi
qualcun'altro deciderà per noi già più o
meno lo stanno facendo
io penso che siamo ancora in tempo anche
perché conoscendo la complessità della
robotica so benissimo che non tutto è
ancora definito non è troppo tardi
il messaggio che lancio è impegnatevi
cercate di capire la complessità che
andrete a vivere e il cambiamento
cambiamento che è a 360 gradi intorno a
noi come ricordate l'esempio della
fabbrica cioè non dovette affrontare
problemi nuovi con schemi mentali vecchi
la società cambierà cambierà cambiare
gli schemi di produzione non sarà più
necessario lavorare così tanto per fare
certe cose però non è detto che questo
significhi disoccupazione significa da
fare altre cose e per esempio dedicarsi
a un sacco di attività nelle quali oggi
c'è una carenza assoluta tutte le
attività di cura per esempio tutte le
attività che richiedono una relazione
fra esseri umani
io non posso pensare e lo dico da
robotico che una macchina potrà mai
sostituire l'aspetto empatico tra due
esseri umani così come non potrà mai
sostituire l'aspetto creativo
dell'essere umano ma noi perché la
macchina non potrà essere creativa io
stesso 20 anni fa progettavo videogames
e e ci metterò dentro algoritmi che
inventavano schemi di gioco ma il
problema è che la nostra creatività il
nostro senso del bello e puramente
nostro noi
macchina potrà essere costruita da noi
per essere bella per piacerci ma saremo
noi che avremmo dato a questa macchina
caratteristiche simboliche estetiche
tali da renderla gradevole e quindi ci
saranno aspetti artistici di design
fondamentali aspetti di programmazione
per interagire con gli esseri umani ma
rimarrà in carica di esseri umani tutto
l'aspetto per esempio della cura prima
parlava della interazione coi bambini
beh il bambino ha bisogno di un essere
umano e quindi un malato ha bisogno
dell'essere umano cioè molti dei guasti
della società odierna sono proprio
perché nessuno si prende cura degli
esseri umani chi si prende cura di una
puerpera voi conoscete immagine il
problema di avere un bambino bene la
società non se ne per chi si prende cura
di chi è malato in un ospedale ogni
tanto sporadicamente ci può essere
qualche sostegno psicologico chi si
prende cura di chi subisce traumi chi si
prende cura di assicurare ai bambini uno
sviluppo mentale che permetta loro di
essere adulti consapevoli compiuti e non
persone dotate di turbe psichiche che li
portano poi a essere quelli che
devastano la società diventando magari
presidente di qualche stato che vuol far
tirare una bomba perché da bambino
nessuno lo ha curato attenzione sembra
sembravano una barzelletta ma questo è
un grave problema ecco quindi che ci
sarà un grande bisogno di esseri umani
grande bisogno di attività umana e
lasciamo pure che i robot facciano le
cose che a noi in fondo non interessa
fare e quindi il futuro mi sto
descrivendo i dettagli del sud io non lo
so come sarà il futuro il futuro è
sempre in movimento
però una cosa è certa per entrare in
questo futuro bisognerà
vedere la prossima slide e quindi
bisognerà fare appello come dicevo prima
le nostre competenze la nostra capacità
l'anno sente vigenza emotiva che è stata
secondo me abbastanza piallata negli
ultimi secoli c'è un disegno conscia o
inconscia che ha progressivamente
separato le due culture per esempio che
ha separato scienza tecnologia dalle
primarie chiuse dalle scienze umane ma
questo è sbagliato
leonardo era tutto non era solo una
delle due cose e noi questo dobbiamo
tornare ad essere e un è uno scienziato
robotico di fatto è costretto ad essere
questo perché come vi dicevo occorre
occuparsi dalla meccanica alla
psicologia e quindi questo importante
portarlo nelle scuole portarlo
nell'educazione non sono concetti nuovi
basti pensare montessori basti pensare a
chi ha inventato il cus tv smo aperte
che l'ha tradotta però sono concetti
abbastanza scarsamente applicati si
pensa che la buona scuola sia fare tanta
bella burocrazia nola buona scuola è
raderà al suolo un certo tipo di
educazione puramente nozionistica
puramente dedicata a costruire uomini
robot dedicate a costruire impiegati a
costruire operai a costruire schiavi e
creare una scuola che invece
costruiscano mm perché solo dei bambini
di oggi che da adulti saranno in grado
di gestire chiaramente la complessità
potranno essere in grado di implementare
la roboetica se no sarà una battaglia
perduta rapidamente ecco perché è una
ventina d'anni fa abbiamo fondato questa
associazione che si chiama scuola di
robotica che non vuole far diventare
tutti i bambini e le bambine scienziati
robotici perché sarebbe effettivamente
crudeltà
vuole invece appunto aiutare i bambini a
comprendere cos'è la robotica
comprendere cos'è il futuro comprendere
cos'è la tecnologia di usare la
tecnologia per comprendere la natura per
comprendere se stessi perché quando uno
gioca come in questo caso con un piccolo
umanoide questa line up challenge vedete
questa bambina in braccio un piccolo
umanoide anche questa sono quelle now il
piccolo umanoide abbastanza economico
usato per scopi sostanzialmente
didattici comincia a capire ci si
specchia in questo tipo di tecnologia si
comincia a capire come funziona è roba
per programmare questa robot si comincia
a pensare a come funziona ma noi e
soprattutto si abbatte questa barriera
io sono qui e lì c'è il robot la
robotica
bisogna che tutti si avvicinino a questa
tecnologia per comprenderla per essere
attori e non spettatori del futuro che
ci aspetta
e quando dico tutti dico anche l'altra
metà del cielo perché è noto che le
bambine non capiscono la matematica
è un grosso problema grosso problema ma
perché non la capiscono perché non
gliele insegniamo perché gli mettiamo in
testa che loro da grandi devono fare le
veline
ecco dov'è il problema e quindi esiste
questo progetto che si chiama roberta
che gli scorre robot è un progetto
europeo iniziato nel 2002 come scuole
robotica partecipiamo attivamente che ha
lo scopo di avvicinare le bambine alla
scienza la tecnologia ma non vogliamo
che diventino scienziate robotiche
vogliamo che capiscano che le squadre di
bambine quando facciamo le gare sono più
brave delle squadre di bambini e questo
è il messaggio qui si dimentichino i
robot ma porteranno nella testa per
sempre che loro possono essere anche in
questo settore più brave dei maschietti
ultimo perché il tempo è ampiamente
finito l'ultima slide altro progetto
stiamo parlando sempre di futuro della
robotica bella roba che non è solo fare
delle demo costosissime sofisticatissime
per fare bella figura a mettere un umana
ed è incredibile no
la robotica deve servire a qualcosa in
questo caso questa è un progetto
internazionale
si chiama enabled c'è un numero
elevatissimo di bambini che nascono con
malformazioni che praticamente non hanno
un brunch non hanno una mano e non
possiamo dare a tutti i bambini quella
brano che avete visto prima costosissima
bellissima sofisticatissima anche perché
i bambini crescono
chiunque abbia visto un bambino sa che
ogni anno bisogna cambiare le scarpine e
allora come si fa ogni anno a cambiargli
una protesi che magari costa 100.000
euro
ed ecco che in questo modo questo
significa che i bambini non hanno
possibilità e invece in questo modo
vedete sfruttando appunto alla rete
sfruttando le nuove possibilità e makers
le nuove possibilità data delle
stampanti 3d dal rapid prototyping dal
dalle organizzazioni open source questo
progetto mette a disposizione infinita
di file già pronti che poi crescono
continuamente i ragazzi di pigliano e
modificandoli al giorno per costruire
con pochissime lire con pochissimi soldi
protesi per i bambini che non possono
accedere a quelle super tecnologie nei
rubate l'altra sera in laboratorio un
paio giusto per fare vedere vedete
questa è fatta tra l'altro con plastica
di recupero perché poi abbiamo un altro
progetto che recupera la plastica nel
mare l'attrice alla ri usa è proprio un
esempio questo adesso rubato laboratorio
in realtà dei tiranti queste di tina
adesso la stavano montando che quando il
bambino spiega il braccio del manine si
chiudono e semplicissima non c'è
elettronica in questo momento qui dentro
però con pochissimi soldi il bambino può
partecipare alla sua costruzione può
scegliere il colore
addirittura abbiamo una collaborazione
con l'architettura qualcuno se la fa
fare tipo goldrake non è solo l'aspetto
fisico anche l'aspetto psicologico un
bambino si avvicina alla propria
visibilità con un atteggiamento
differente poi avere un altro progetto
che invece integrante dei piccoli
sensori la posare come una bacchetta
magica come un mouse 3d nello spazio per
fare delle cose e è solo un esempio
questa è una un po più grande vedete
tutta roba che non costa nulla ma che
può fare la differenza per una persona
che a questo tipo di problemi e quindi
fare questo è un lavoro o no o è un
hobby o curarsi del prossimo ecco io
meno male che ci rubano quei lavori che
ci impediscono di fare queste cose molto
più utili per l'umanità
grazie
[Applauso]